Let's get back to the phones where folks are
eagerly awaiting with questions and comments.
At six one seven eight three zero.
Forty seven fifty.
Let's go to our caller from the four oh five
area code is four or five Northern California.
Hello? Yes, that's you, can you hear me?
Yes, I can't.
OK.
No.
Four or five is actually in Oklahoma.
But my family moved from Oklahoma to Virginia,
actually.
And our area code is two seven six, I think.
But I never changed my phone number.
Beautiful.
Never got it updated.
I just have two quick questions for you.
They're not really.
It's pretty complicated subject, but I'm actually
16, so I can't vote yet.
Larry, unfortunately, and I've been.
I just got introduced to the political space
ever since the Corona virus, you know, hit
and started ravaging the world and everything.
So I was wondering, as a 16 year old, how
can I help the democratic cause?
Obviously, and it's not a guarantee whatsoever
and anything can happen and there is no absolute
guarantee that we can win.
Right.
So listen, in the immediate you can't vote,
but you can phone bank.
Okay.
So you can figure out, do you want to phone
bank for Joe Biden?
Do you want to phone bank for some particular
Senate race or House race?
So so I think that's one area.
I don't think there's any restrictions on
16 year olds campaigning in other ways.
So you can get in.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but I believe you
can get involved in campaigns in a variety
of different ways.
I would also remind you that in the midterms
that are just two years away, you will be
able to vote by then.
So certainly that you're very, very close
to really plan on it.
Yeah, I definitely plan on voting by then.
And my second question.
Well, thank you for the answer.
But my second question is, do you think my
generation is going to bring anything new
to the table?
Because obviously the entire political spectrum
right now is very corrupt.
Everyone's just doing what they can do to
win and they don't actually care about the
average person.
So do you think the millennial generation
and my generation will actually change anything,
or do you think it's just the kind of ongoing
pattern that will never end and we're just
going to be stuck in this endless cycle?
So I think the answer is yes, we will.
You will if we and you want to.
And if you look back in history, there's always
been this idea that whatever is the up and
coming generation, they're lazy, they're burn
outs.
They're not going to do it.
You know, this was said during about the hippie
movement in the 60s and 70s.
They're not going to do anything except for
the ones that went to Vietnam because they
were drafted there.
They just want to hang out and smoke pot and
go to Woodstock and all of this stuff.
It's been said about the millennial generation.
It's been said about some of the, you know,
now younger than millennials, older, they're
lazy.
And because of they grew up with technology
and this and that.
Listen, every single one of these generations,
if we want to if they want to, is going to
be able to change the system.
But it comes down to understanding that you
need to get involved and involved in a serious
way.
And if not, then it'll just be more of the
same, as you're correctly pointing out.
Yeah.
Well, thanks.
Thank you so much for the feedback.
I just wondered what your thoughts where you
been?
You've been this kind of voice of reason.
I've been following your lives, dreams and
thoughts.
I'm excited for the debates and hopefully
it doesn't completely go wrong for Joe Biden.
I hope he wins.
Thank you for being the voice of reason in
this time of chaos.
Thank you for calling in.
I'm so glad that you're engaging in politics
at a young age.
And listen, the debates could go wrong for
Trump, too.
Don't underestimate that possibility.
That, too.
Yeah.
All right, my friend.
Thank you.
Great to hear from you.
Let's go next.
Continuing our tour of the United States via
phone.